you sat in this section what would you
like a freestyle rap about
my sex life
um and it's quite personal thing isn't
it I don't in in the in the UK
um it's not something we would discuss
can I have a a vocation that means job
sorry
a dentist cool I'm gonna I'm gonna say
my sex life if I was a dentist just to
protect uh the wrap from 40 seconds of
Silence While I Cry
[Laughter]
sex life if I was a dentist we'll come
to this Enclave over here what would you
like a rap about Queen Elizabeth okay so
so Queen Elizabeth feels too British
what did you say about what
five-year-old children cool do you do
you teach
do you have a five-year-old child
why would you
you're lucky you have a feminine voice
because
you know
five-year-old children
do you teach no I wish I wish I did
five-year-old children why not
five-year-old children sex like a
dentist if someone over here was just
going no
you sound like a five-year-old child so
stay away from that person
I guess uh we'll come to the back of the
room next so back in the room what you
want to rap about
Robert De Niro stalker is this is this a
oh oh yeah
um is this a true thing he has a stalker
yeah
cool okay no I haven't read the news
story but that's that's very it's very
sad isn't it it's not nice to be stopped
Robert De Niro stalker
um this this this section of the room
suggestion number four What's it gonna
be
you just said Harry Kane I told you
specifically you can't say that it was
that a lady who said feet okay cool what
how would you describe your ideal foot
nice
but low [__] standards you guys have
and then so what do you mean by nice you
know like well moisturized well groomed
what size what's the ideal foot size
and eight
one [__] tiny penis man
sorry unless you're talking about you
know you know women in which case that's
a good foot I'm sorry sorry for assuming
so okay so the ideal for a size eight
foot
sex life of me if I was a dentist it's
pretty good Robert De Niro's stalker
yeah we like that and the one over here
was
called five year olds
and then you guys you get suggestion
number five is the final one
so renting an apartment in New York and
you said
twins twins renting an apartment in New
York
thank you it makes it fun these are
these are quite good because last night
we did a couple of shows and the
suggestions were pretty pretty dog [__]
weren't they red but tonight they've
come through so if the rap is bad it's
my fault for a change
uh band I would love you to produce one
of your marvelous pieces of music and
and like we said
I mean I'm surprised that that's how it
started as well
I'm excited it's gonna be good uh this
is a freestyle like I said made up on
the spot about all that stuff it's gonna
be lovely it's gonna be exciting it's
gonna be live yeah
rap's Gonna Be Live is what the British
guy told person over there shouting out
five-year-old not a teacher and not a
parent so it's scary walking in the
playground you should be aware these
ladies they like to lurk there by the
swing see the toddlers while they're
moving in ask someone how old are you I
adore if you're six if you're four no I
want more one in the middle three six
five times five with the extra day the
leap year provides five-year-olds they
understand sarcasm that's a true fact
otherwise there's a large chasm in the
understanding if you say no and mean yes
they're not as cotton in or not
impressed a five-year-old it can't be
beat but if you met one with size 8 fee
you would be confused what the [__]
going non-stop it why is this
five-year-old just like a hobby with
massive little hairy feet on the floor
you said nice the type I adore not long
there with unmanicured claws leaving
those marks on your wood floors gotta
get the laminate or maybe trim the nail
size hey I don't know but if you were
male that'd be quite small I'd be living
the dream I'm just showing off now I got
the size 13 that'd be massive oh yeah
what a pick if I was a dentist I'd have
a huge dick I'd be walking in swinging
around getting all the laughing gas if
you have found me on Yelp or reviews on
Google you come in and sit down then I
might doodle you that's a euphemism for
having sex but of course you have to
consent first yes I put it on the form
we can film porn you were like I just
had a pain in my jaw but shut up I'm
gonna dislocate it now when I give you a
deep throat holy cow so rude and that's
how I live my life apologies to my lady
wife if she watches this you know that's
not how it happened my gosh living here
right in Manhattan it's very difficult
it's not as fun in a studio apartment
you need income doubled up so you can
save yourself a lot of trouble get
yourself a sibling then you're doing
double on the rent checks oh yes you
know you're in share a bed why cause
you're just twins you shared a womb
shared a whole placenta maybe you would
argue about who gets the center who uses
the bathroom first or the shower twins
in New York yes I admire wasn't there
some type of stuff like Mary Kay and
Ashley New York minute this guy's
looking at me like yes I'm a fan of
those two ladies I love them when they
were five years old babies doesn't make
sense but that's okay we talked there
watch out if you're worried about
stalkers and you starred in The
Godfather and The Godfather too another
part there you were in heat with Al
Pacino for the first time walking around
maybe you'd be 75 or 76 looking old my
plan unless you get cgi'd in the Irish
man that's Robert De Niro one of my
acting Heroes but who's this guy
following him down the road ah a guy in
a big trench coat I go over there and
pick a stick and he got smoked around
the head he falls down I say stop
stalking but it's not the stalker it's a
person who was talking over there she
was confused when I provide you said
Robert Nero was 75 or maybe removed the
70 that worked for me you were going so
berserk yes you know the certainty stay
away from playgrounds and kindergartens
there we go the freestyle rap and that's
a hard one
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]